Dyson is known for revolutionizing the vacuum. Sir
James Dyson hoped to create another revolutionary product -
an electric car to compete with Tesla. The
Dyson car was supposed to be on the road in 2021
but then the project got axed. Constructing cars
at any scale takes blood, sweat, tears, and even
more money. It was too expensive to build. Dyson had
a legacy to protect. So does Sony. The Japanese tech
giant is one of the most recognized brands in the
world, famous for the PlayStation and the Walkman -
if you're old enough to remember it. But no one saw
this coming. Sony took almost everyone by surprise
by unveiling an electric car at the 2020 Consumer
Electronics Show in Las Vegas. This wasn't just a
concept, this was a prototype. The car is drivable.
The team that built Aibo, Sony's cute robotic dog,
built the car with the help of the renowned
Magna Steyr which manufactures vehicles like
the Mercedes-Benz G-Class. This car is called
the Vision-S, Sony's vision for the future.
Mobile has been the mega trend of the last
decade. I believe the next mega trend will be
mobility. Mobility is defined as fundamentally
changing the way we travel. A car won't just be
a way to get from point a to point b. It's a piece
of technology, an iPhone on wheels. The vehicle will
be connected to the internet. It knows the location
of the person it's picking up while the passenger
can also follow the car along its route. The Sony
car is jam-packed with Sony stuff. Touch screen
panoramic Sony displays filled with Sony-owned
movies and music. Each seat has its own speakers
so you wouldn't need to fight over what music to listen to. And if you're listening through your
earbuds before getting into the car, Sony envisions
the music automatically transferring to the
vehicle's speakers. The idea is to make the ride as
comfortable as time spent in your own living room
with the understanding that one day, there
won't even be a driver. Cars will be autonomous.
Sony's is not yet fully autonomous but it is
moving in that direction thanks to a whopping 33
sensors located both inside and outside. According
to the company, the autonomy level of Vision-S
is two or greater. The driver is still in control
but the vehicle is aware of its surroundings.
It can recognize when other obstacles are in
its way before parking and knows when to change
lanes while keeping a safe distance from other vehicles. Sensors can even read the driver's facial
expressions to gauge levels of concentration and fatigue and send out alerts if necessary. And the
temperature will be automatically adjusted
to match the comfort level of people inside.
Sony originally said it had no intention of
mass producing the car. The prototype was simply
developed to show off its technology. But plans may have changed. After its unveiling in Las Vegas,
the car moved to Magna Steyr's engineering
facility in Graz, Austria for fine tuning.
And then in July, Sony announced it would begin
testing the car on roads in Japan. This suggests
the company may have bigger plans for the Vision-S
than simply to advance the sensing and audio
technology for other carmakers to use in their vehicles. It does already dabble in the auto
industry by supplying image sensors to companies
like Toyota to help with automatic emergency
braking. Sony hopes software updates will move its
car up to at least level four which means the
vehicle does all the driving but only in a limited area. The highest level is full self-driving.
The car performs all tasks under all circumstances.
It's the same level Tesla aims to achieve.
Elon Musk's company has completely turned the auto industry upside down.Other electric cars are often
compared to a Tesla. So how does the Vision-S
stack up against Tesla's mass-market Model 3?
Depending on the version of the Model 3,
it can go 0 to 60 mph in 3.1 to 5.3 seconds.
Sony claims its car can accelerate in 4.8seconds.
The top speed of the Tesla ranges from 140
to 162 mph compared to Sony's 149 mph. The
Model 3 has a driving range of 267 to 360 miles.
We don't yet know how far Sony's car can go nor
do we know what price it would be if it does go
on sale one day. If it's more expensive than the
Model 3 and a comparison with the Model S is more
appropriate, it does lag behind in acceleration
and speed.
A big difference between the two companies is
that Sony relies on LiDAR to advance its self-driving technology
LiDAR is a sensor that helps detect objects by
beaming out laser light and then measuring the
the time it takes for the light to reflect back. Musk
once called LiDAR a fool's errand and said anyone
relying on the expensive sensor is doomed. Instead,
Tesla uses a combination of cameras, radar, and
ultrasonics to see. LiDAR is very popular with tech companies other than Tesla. It's found in
Apple's iPhone 12 Pro to help take better photos. And, by the way, Apple is also reportedly wading
into the car market. Rumors of an Apple electric car have run rampant for years. It even hired
a bunch of engineers from Tesla but its efforts have been
shaky from the start with leadership changes and
hundreds of layoffs from the car division a couple of years ago. Apple'sdirection has reportedly shifted to developing
an autonomous driving system rather than a
complete car but who knows what the future holds.
Apple's challenges show just how difficult it
can be even for well-established companies to
build electric cars. Dyson learned that the hard way. But the difficulty doesn't appear to deter
Sony. We are excited about the road ahead of us. It will be a long road ahead.
If Sony does end up producinga car for the masses, be prepared to wait becauseautonomous cars need to clock in a lot of hours
in order to gather enough driving data. Although
Sony hasn't provided many updates about the
development of its car, all the pieces of the
puzzle seem to point to more than just a prototype.
I'm Cindy Pom, thanks for watching. If you like
what you saw, give it a like and don't forget to
subscribe to my channel. And thank you very much to my Patrons for your support. I'll see you next week.